the number 617 830 for 750 I am thrilled
to be joined by our next caller who's on
the line now now do we have the next
caller we do can you hear me call her
hey Wow lacks expecting it on here
you're on what what's your name going on
from I'm Scott and calling from our Ohio
okay great what's on your mind Scott Air
Arm life why know you guys have been
doing a lot of like uh auntie regressive
left videos are kind of stuff yeah
listen I'm i think well let me just say
real quick just because of the framing
of the question what we I've sort of
stepped away from the term regressive
left because I feel like it's become a
catch-all to just insult liberals and uh
critique any idea that conservatives
don't like basically what i try to do
and i know not everybody agrees that i
succeed is if I see fads on the left
that I find to be fundamentally
authoritarian or a liberal all sort of
call them out uh but yeah okay but my
reframing aside what can we answer about
that I'm curious if you guys would ever
consider going on like one of those arm
and Auntie regressive left like online
podcast videos like gum for example
drunken peasants or something like that
we'll listen I mean I go on shows all
the time that may it intersect partially
uh or or more with my political views so
yeah I mean any any podcast invitation
i'll receive all sort of evaluate the
time requirement and and how much value
I think will be created by by being on
it I would not make the decision to go
on a podcast or not necessarily because
of the political beliefs I mean if some
you know if some white supremacist
podcast with ten listeners comes to me I
would sort of consider the fact that I'd
be speaking to 10 white supremacists in
deciding whether to do the show but I'm
totally open to all invitations from
other podcasts and shows I because yeah
I know you've made that video saying
you wouldn't mind go on to those so that
I wanted to see because they said they
were looking for people on the show so I
thing and maybe you could contact them
earth day to contact you whatever a
little we can I think that one's way you
are uh I don't know if you work in PR
but you're absolutely uh greasing wheels
here and making connections between
people I am I would be thrilled to
entertain an email from the drunken
peasants and I really really appreciate
the call thanks so much d two calls from
the south and one from Ohio today